President Trump was at mar-a-lago when
word came down about the Muller report
Nikole Killion is traveling with the
president and is in West Palm Beach
Nicole good morning good morning to you
Adriana and we don't expect to see
President Trump today because he has no
public events on his schedule but he did
appear pretty upbeat
last night take a look at some video
from a local Republican Party dinner
that was held at his mar-a-lago club
press weren't allowed in but CBS News
obtained it from a state GOP official
who was in attendance the president did
not mention the Mullah report in his
remarks the official there told me that
president seemed happy and was smiling
and grinning during the event first lady
was also there as was his son Donald
Trump jr. now earlier in the day the
president met with Caribbean leaders at
mar-a-lago and before arriving he again
called the mother probe a big hoax and a
witch-hunt a White House official says
that some of the president's lawyers are
here with him in mar-a-lago a justice
spokesperson says that the Attorney
General's chief of staff actually
notified one of them shortly before the
news broke yesterday Michelle all right
Nikole Killion thank you